the mazda3 has been an old acquaintance
of the gulf line for several years it's
been successful around the world
it hasn't beat out the Gulf or a3 yet
but it's definitely in the running to
ensure that that continues Mazda has
given its compact a facelift
the current third generation has been
around since 2013
[Music]
car tester Emmanuel Schaefer notes that
up to now the Mazda 3 has often been
criticized for its relatively hard
suspension that made it fairly nimble
but at the cost of comfort the facelift
improves the comfort without sacrificing
agility the Mazda 6 is G vectoring
control system has been installed in the
Mazda 3 towards mine that's vectoring
control makes minimal adjustments to the
engines torque thereby influencing
steering and stabilizing driving
behavior specifically when you steer
into a curve vectoring control very
briefly reduces the amount of fuel
injected and thus the amount of torque
this shoots the weight to the front axle
giving it more traction and improving
steering
[Music]
this was a facelift not a new model so
the changes aren't drastic one
difference the chrome bar no longer
extends over the headlamps
[Music]
the trunk holds 364 leaders or would the
back seat down 1263 leaders in
particular the manual says the current
generation 3 Mazda has often been
criticized for the poor or at least
average quality of the materials used in
the interior now this is changed
everything is very chic and well-crafted
he likes the title II arranged
instruments only one thing bothers him
the clefts around the sat-nav don't
match the rest otherwise he finds the
interior design quite pleasing isn't the
person emitting restos I'm a balanced
and reassuring about the 5-door Mazda 3
offers a choice of five engines three
gasoline and two diesel the 1.5 liter
basic gasoline engine is available only
with the 5-door version if you want this
engine for the four-door sedan version
of the Mazda 3 you're out of luck
the editability Emmanuelle provides some
specs the two litre gasoline engine in
our test car produces 88 kilowatts that
doesn't sound like much but it's okay if
you consider that it also delivers
respectable torque the lack of a
turbocharger means you'll have to rev it
up a bit but once you pass 3000 rpm
you'll move forward quickly this engine
is certainly powerful enough to keep up
with traffic it's a filler the
manufacturer says the Mazda 3 consumes
an average of 5 litres per 100
kilometres top speed is 195 kilometers
an hour
[Music]
with the right equipment package the
Mazda 3 has the ie loop energy recovery
system which stores braking energy
produced in a condenser for use in the
electric powered systems Emmanuelle says
the Mazda 3 facelift involves many small
and some big changes that make the
vehicle much better overall and yet the
price has not increased significantly
that makes the Mazda 3 a stronger rival
for its competitors from VW and Audi the
basic price of the Mazda 3 is 18,000 190
euros in Germany
you